the last few days we have been doing
extensive planning across government
departments and with our International
Partners to take advantage of any
Improvement in the situation and begin
the evacuation of British Nationals in
Sudan I'm very pleased that a ceasefire
has been announced by the leadership of
the factions on the ground and therefore
we are initiating an evacuation plan it
is important to remember that ceasefires
have been announced and have fallen
apart in the past so the situation
remains dangerous volatile and
unpredictable
I've spoken either directly or through
intermediaries with the leaders of the
factions on the ground
calling for them to allow British
Nationals dual Nationals and miners
to be evacuated and we will continue to
push for the maintenance of this
ceasefire of course it is impossible for
us to predict how long this opportunity
will last and we're calling people
forward in priority order based on their
vulnerability we've heard a lot in the
past couple of days about how dangerous
the situation in Sudan is how are people
going to get to this Airfield safely
well the truth is that we cannot predict
how the situation on the ground will
develop the the conflict has as I say
been unpredictable it's been volatile we
have said that we are unable to provide
escorts from where British Nationals are
to the Airhead they will have to make
their own way uh there as indeed has
been the case for uh the Nationals of
other countries we will maintain this
ahead for as long as we can but the
situation does remain as I say dangerous
and volatile
it's going to be still risky for people
to make their way to the airport do you
accept that and how quickly do you want
to get this done as a result
well we are working as quickly as
possible obviously the UK is not the
only country seeking to evacuate its
Nationals and we are doing this
evacuation in close coordination with
our International Partners this is a an
active conflict the ceasefire has been
announced but we know that there have
been pockets of violence in the past
even within uh previous ceasefires so
this does remain dangerous this does
remain difficult we are providing what
assistance that we can and we're
operating as quickly as we can
we saw what happened in Afghanistan
where there was a rush on Kabul Airport
how worried are you that that could
happen again and do you have plans in
place to prevent that
well this situation is fundamentally
different to the situation in
Afghanistan we have established a
contact with a number of British
Nationals and we are talking where we
can directly with them although we
recognize our ability to maintain uh
consistent Communications is difficult
because of the conflict we are
prioritizing calling forward the most
vulnerable the young the old those who
are unwell or who are injured and we
will make contact with them directly as
I say we want to maintain this ceasefire
as long as possible we want to maximize
the number of British Nationals that we
help but this does remain an
unpredictable and dangerous circumstance
a lot of people will be wondering this
morning why you didn't do this sooner
other countries have been taking people
out of Sudan a lot earlier than the UK
have you waited too long
well the circumstances for each
individual Nation are different there
are considerably more British Nationals
in Sudan than other countries have got
we've been working closely with our
International partners and we have
facilitated the
um evacuation of a number of British
Nationals already we will continue to
work with our International Partners we
will continue to push for a maintenance
of this ceasefire with the generals
commanding the troops in Sudan and I
will continue my direct engagement with
them to make sure that the British
Nationals who need to be evacuated are
facilitated to the AirHead and
ultimately out of Sudan finally how
confident are you that all the Brits who
want to get out of Sudan will get out
are you looking at other options for
example in Port sedan
we have always maintained a rage a range
of options for evacuation it is
impossible to predict how long the
ceasefire will last it's impossible to
predict how long any other route to
evacuation will remain open we will
continue to push the leadership in Sudan
to maintain this ceasefire to facilitate
the evacuation of British Nationals and
that is something we will do both
directly and with our International
Partners but on at this stage it's not
possible for us to predict with any
certainty at all the circumstances on
the ground in Sudan